bonjour je m'appelle flan PAVI je suis
technicien enedis région Centre
valdeoire basé sur la base
opérationnelle d'Orléan ok donc le
chantier ça consiste à changer les
attaches sur les poteau
79 81 aujourd'hui on va faire un travail
de rénovation programmée de nos ouvrages
pour gagner en qualité de fourniture
c'estàd qu'on va changer tout ce qui est
armement sur les poteau isolateur même
si les fils sont abîmés on va les
changer donc voilà c'est pour gagner en
efficience sur la sur la qualité de four
tous les jours on fait pas la même chose
c'estd que on peut travailler en
centreville on peut travailler dans les
dans les champs comme ici par tous les
temps qui neige qui qui aille du vent
qu' aille de la grêle de l'orage une
tempête voilà on est tout tout le temps
dehors il y a une grande diversité sur
sur nos métiers on fait jamais la même
chose et c'est ça ce qui me
plaît les colollèg c'est aussi avant
tout des amis on s'entend vraiment tous
les uns et les autres et c'est ce qui
fait que le travail tous les jours et de
plus en plus
agréable c'est des nouvelles technologie
ça m'a attiré c'est c'est une mission
qui est complet inventaire de mon métier
et j'en suis très satisfait il me permet
maintenant dans le cadre du dépannage
d'être plus réactif quand il y a une
panne et d'aller la trouver dans des
milieux qui sont compliqués d'accès tels
que la Sologne où il y a les bois et ça
permet d'être très réactif pour la
réalimentation des
clients ça fait déjà 25 ans que je suis
chez enedis c'est vrai que cette
évolution au sein de de
l'entreprise fait que je suis toujours
un peu mixte sur le sur le terrain et
mix aussi au bureau vraiment cette
polyvalence fait que dans mon métier je
je suis vraiment épanoui c'est un métier
qui permet de bouger et d'être au
contact avec la nature ce que j'aime
aussi